t'imagines à un vrai parc d'attraction
en plein paris ça ce serait cool bas il
y en a déjà eu plusieurs même au centre
ville affirmatif intra muros absolument
mal tivoli par exemple picot deux
secondes je te montre tout commence en
1730 week-end zain sur la france est le
premier parc de loisirs de france
s'appelle tivoli illégaux comme
attraction alors la technologie étant ce
qu'elle est et c'est surtout un
libertinage
mais progressivement on y installe des
manèges des montagnes
une grande roue et en tirent des feux
d'artifice libertinage est grande
fallait y penser
il ya aussi le fameux tir aux pigeons
qui à l'époque se dresse sur de répit
gens en disant tu plus de 300 milles
puis il part ferme en 1842 on pouffe qui
joue à temps c'est pas ton on apprenait
jusqu'ici aux enfants les sept
merveilles du monde
il en est maintenant au huitième la
brillante inauguration de luna park la
ville enchantée élevé à la porte maillot
par les célèbres manager en ville gaston
akoun nous l'a prouvé hier soir
balade en gondole descente de rapides
palais des folies ouvert tous les jours
de 13 heures à minuit
je crois qu'on tient là l'origine des
ghosts of mais là la roue infernale
surnommé le tortillard humain c'est un
instrument de torture ou quoi non ça
devait juste fait les tournées et ça
cartonne
un mois après l'ouverture il annonce les
chiffres de la fréquentation du parc
et ça aussi ça file de tourner c'est une
semaine de véritable hiver que nous
venons au passé et bien malgré le froid
malgré la pluie les entrées de cette
quatrième semaine entrer dans le parc
seulement sans compter les entrées aux
attractions on était de 134 86 le parc
est régulièrement renouvelés ils
organisent aussi bien des concours des
scream que des discours de président ça
a cartonné
enfin ça a cartonné mais si je ne
m'abuse il n'existe plus ouais petite
erreur de positionnement au moment de la
seconde guerre mondiale la direction a
un peu trop
avec l'envahisseur et ils mettent la clé
sous la porte en 1948
game over pour eux mais ça n'a pas été
le seul parc d'attractions parisien il
ya eu magic city la plus grande cité
féerique du monde
ah ouais là niveau comme il n'était pas
mauvais ouverture en 1910 en 1914
ça devient un centre d'entraînement
militaire metal gear solid chez disney
weight presque en 1927 il organise même
une kermesse au profit des comédiens de
combattants et là aussi des meetings
politiques des galas et même des combats
luc celui-là il a fermé en 1934
voilà un an pêche ça manque ce genre
d'endroit à paris la sq il faut pas si
loin oui mais quand même un truc dans le
centre ça serait cool
je crois qu'il ya plus trop de place
dans son antre tu verras comme sur le
champ-de-mars valentine landes
géraud city j'ai roulante incity landes
ouais non mais laisse tomber on verra
plus tard pour le monde j'aimais bien
géré aux lentilles hockey
[Musique]
on
à
comment